THIS SEASON.
THIS GAME WAS AWAY. THROWN IN O
>> Butch: RIELLY GETS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
GOAL.
>> Butch: YOU'VE G GAS STRIPPED
STARTED SLOW IN A NUMBER OF
GAMES.
>> Brendan: THEY WILL HAVE TO
TR IT DOWN FOR
WALL.
MATTHEWS COUGHS IT UP.
MAYFIELD SLAPS IT OVER TO THE IY
MITCH MARNER.E JOIN THE PESDAY.
SHELDON KEEFE WHO CALLED HIS
TEAM SOFT AND PURPOSELESS.
SOFT IST SHORTHANDED.
MARNER IS IN.
HE LOST IT AND I RACES.
THEY'RE COMING BACK.MOVES.
DOBSON PUT IT OFF OF PAGEAU.
COUNT CONNECT.
>> Butch: GOOD CENTER.
KNOCKED DOWN BY PA PARISE HEADI
DOWN THE WING, A CHIP PASS, AND
PARISE.
WHAT A GREAT GOAL.
BOUNCING PUCK, SMART ENOUGH T T.
A GOOD PLAY
ENG VAIL WITH A CHANCE.
BACKHAND AND HE ENOUGH.
>> Butch: NOPE.
THAT'S GOING TO
HE KNOWS HE SCORED THE GOAL.
HE'S OUT THEREHAT'S VERY,
VERY TALENTED.
DOBSON O
MORGAN RIELLY. LIKE TRYING TO VA
POSITION WITH SKATE OUT AND CLO
THE AN
OPPORTUNITYSHOOTS.
ABLE TO GET A QUICK LITTLE PASS
FROM BROCK NELSON.OES A LITTLE .
MRAZEK CAME OUT ELEVATED CROSSIG
NO ONE'S GOING AT THE IN FRONT.
.
THEY NEED TO GET THE PUCK IN TH
PENALTY.
>> Brendan: BARZAL HASPELBACKHA
BACK
MAKES A PASS ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF JOSH BAILEY AND THAT'S KIND
OF H NEEDED TO GET SOME
OFFENSE GOING.